Hello and welcome
everyone. It's Active Inference guest
stream number 48.1 on July 19,
2023. We're here with Arthur Giuliani
and Adam Safron, also joined by Michael
Edward Johnson in discussion. We're
going to have a presentation and then a
conversation about deep canals, a deep
learning approach to refining the
cannilization theory of psychopathology.
So thank you all for joining and looking
forward to this presentation and
discussion.
Thanks Daniel. I'm very happy to be here
with Admin Mike to talk about this work
and to discuss more broadly this general
direction that's emerged over the past
few years to try to utilize some of the
concepts from the active inference world
and computational modeling more
generally to understand what's going on
both in psychopathology and in
psychedelic therapy. Yeah, so I'll give
a brief presentation and we'll
move into a kind of more general
discussion of this work.
It'll start with some kind of general
considerations around psychedelic
therapy, some of the neuroscience of
psychedelics, and then move kind of more
specifically into the model.
So there is this class of drugs, these
serotonergic psychedelic drugs, which
include psilocybin, DMT, LSD and others.
And the past decade has seen a
resurgence of interest in psychedelic
therapy, psychedelic assisted
psychotherapy, where one or
multiple of these drugs is used in
conjunction with a kind of
psychotherapeutic protocol. And there's
been a lot of investment of money and
time and clinical resources into
utilizing these drugs for treatments
depression, anxiety disorders,
substance use disorders and others.
And there seems to be quite a lot of
positive signals suggesting that these
kinds of therapeutic interventions can
actually be quite effective. So there's
a number of studies suggesting that
psilocybin assisted psychotherapy can be
helpful for depression, anxiety,
substance use disorder and others. And
as this work advances, there are more
and more larger clinical trials
comparing it for example, to the
standard treatments with SSRIs,
with multiple studies suggesting that
pilocybin assisted psychotherapy is at
least as effective as the Lexapro
kind of standard of care.
All of this seems to suggest, and the
timelines are kind of pointing at this
idea, that psilocybin
treatment for major depressive disorder
may be only a couple of years away from
becoming approved as an
actual treatment in the United States.
Which means that it's quite important
for us to understand what's going on
mechanistically in the brain so that
these kinds of treatments can be best
optimized, best determined how to be
used for
which kinds of mental issues people
might be having, and under what kinds of
treatment protocols we might expect the
most success. I think this
will also ultimately, hopefully lead to
the development of even better drugs,
even better treatment protocols and much
more personalized care.
So some of the basics of how these drugs
work on the brain for those who are
unfamiliar, so these are the
serotonergic psychedelics. They are
serotonergic because they act as
agonists for a number of serotonin
receptors in the brain and the central
nervous system. More broadly, it's
thought that most specifically these
drugs like psilocybin work through
agonizing, the serotonin five H T
two A receptor. And this has
been demonstrated multiple
times by using blockers antagonists
of the five H T two A receptor which
seem to largely remove the effect of
psilocybin or other psychedelic drugs.
And what this two A receptor does when
it's agonized is it excites the neuron,
making it more likely to fire. And this
is kind of essential to some of the
downstream effects.
So given that it seems that this two
way receptor that psychedelics are
mainly targeting, the question then
becomes well, where in the brain are
these two A receptors? Most widely
expressed? And research has focused
on, I would say, three kind of key areas
over the past decade or so. The first
being the thalamus, which is a region
involved in the gating of sensory
information into the cortex.
There's a lot of expression in the
cortex itself, expression for example,
in the visual system, which is perhaps
not surprising given the prevalence of
visual hallucinations and psychedelic
use. But therapeutically a lot of focus
has been on the prefrontal cortex where
there is also a dense expression of
these receptors. And then also more
recent work has looked at the claustrom
which is a small brain region
responsible for coordinating the
transition dynamics of cortical
activation. And this too is likely
of central importance to the psychedelic
effect.
So kind of moving up one level of
abstraction to fMRI studies, there are a
few kind of like key takeaways which
have been identified from a few
different fMRI studies looking at
psychedelic use.
Kind of the main theme has
largely been this idea of increased
entropy or increased complexity of the
cortical activation in the brain.
So there are various measures of this.
On the right here there's a figure of
one of the common measures of complexity
and looking at various
different kinds of states that an
individual might be in and how that
relates to complexity. So you have
individuals in vegetative states or
anesthesized states having relatively
low brain activity complexity, you have
individuals in awake states having
higher complexity and then individuals
who have ingested either psilocybin or
LSD showing the highest brain
complexity.
Now, along with this, rather than just
this kind of like single unified score,
there's work looking particularly at the
changes in functional connectivity
between different brain regions or
different brain networks. And the
general trend seems to be that you have
decreased within network functional
connectivity and increase between
network functional connectivity, which
this kind of can be interpreted as
different brain networks which typically
don't communicate as much with each.
Other, more likely to communicate with
each other undo the effects of
psychedelics and the kind
of like internal coherence of networks
is reduced under psychedelics.
People have maybe heard of this default
mode network right, which is responsible
for a lot of self referential processing
which is responsible, which is typically
activated, for example, when individuals
are off task, mind wandering, not
actively engaged. The default mode
network has been kind of consistently
implicated in being having less of this
kind of like within network
connectivity, less of this functional
integration. And this has been
hypothesized to be one of the kind of
key mechanisms of the therapeutic effect
of psychedelics.
In addition to looking at kind of like
brain network activity on a high level,
you can then also zoom in much more
deeply and look at what's actually going
on at the neuron by neuron level or the
neuron connectivity level.
Here we see kind of very certain, very
consistent story around this
psychoplastogenic effect or this
neuroplastogenic effect, where there are
a number of different markers of
increased plasticity in the brain. So
one that's very common is this increased
brain derived neurotropic factor which
we see hours after psychedelic use for
a variety of different psychedelic
drugs. And this is then accompanied a
few hours later by visible increases in
the dendritic spine growth in
cortical parameter neurons. So this is
both the number of dendritic spines and
the complexity of the spines. You can
see a very clear example of this here on
the right, where you have on the top the
vehicle and then the bottom the DMT
treated pyramidal neuron.
And the difference is very stark. You
don't even have to do any sort of actual
computational analysis for it to be
clear that there's quite significant
dendritic growth from a single dosing.
And the changes to functional
connectivity, which I mentioned in the
previous slide, tend to persist, though
in a less extreme form than
what we see during the acute effects.
So the question then becomes, given all
of this, how can we attempt to tell
a consistent computational story,
what's actually going on during both the
acute effects, the post acute effects,
and in terms of the actual downstream
therapeutic outcomes?
So what's kind of been proposed as
one of the leading models of this
is the relaxed belief under psychedelics
model, the Rebus model of Carhartt,
Harris and Tristan. And so this builds
on the kind of like active inference,
hierarchical predictive processing
framework where we can understand the
brain as this series of predictors
stacked kind of like hierarchically
along brain networks.
And predictions are being made
by higher level networks that are
attempting to predict the errors
of lower level networks. And the
process of basically doing this then
produces this series of belief
landscapes at different levels of
spatiotemporal abstraction.
And these belief landscapes, of course,
can encode beliefs with various levels
of precision. And it's the
modulation of the precision of these
beliefs which is believed to take place
under psychedelic use.
So here's kind of like a very high level
version of this Rebus model and how
belief relaxation might actually happen,
right? So given that you have this
series of cortical networks which are
representing beliefs at different
spatiotemporal scales. We can kind of
think of the thalamus as being kind of
like the entry point where sensory
information is being gated into this
hierarchical system and the prefrontal
cortex as being kind of like one of the
highest level. Networks, which is then
responsible for both representing
the most abstract kinds of beliefs as
well as being kind of the primary
inhibiting force for all of the
downstream beliefs in the network, in
the system. So what is
this heavy agonism of the five h T two A
receptor supposed to be doing in this
case? Well, it's going to be decreasing
the prefrontal cortex's ability to make
coherent predictions and coherent
representations of belief, which will
then disrupt its ability to inhibit
lower levels of the cortical hierarchy.
At the same time, by disrupt this
activation of the Salamic or
this disruption of the thalamic gating
is going to result in additional sensory
information entering the cortex that
wouldn't underwise enter the cortex.
You have these kind of disruptions at
these two levels which then
result in beliefs being
spontaneously represented in ways that
they wouldn't normally be represented.
And the Rebus model at least is
suggesting that this mainly is going to
manifest itself as a kind of relaxation
of these beliefs.
So here is a kind of like very simple
diagram of what this might look like.
So you have some landscape of beliefs
here and you can kind of interpret
the position along the
X and Y or, I guess, the X and Z belief
in A as being corresponding to some
particular belief that might be
represented by the network at this layer
or at this level of representation. And
then the Y axis, the height as being the
actual precision of that belief. Right?
So here we have this kind of very deep
part on the right part of this network
or on this landscape and this would
be a very strongly represented belief.
Let's say what the acute
effects of psychedelics are then
understood to be doing right is to be
flattening this landscape to be less
strongly representing these strongly
represented beliefs to maybe making it
easier for the reversal
of this landscape. So to move from one
attractor state to another tractor
state,
which is meant to be understood to be
kind of therapeutic in various ways,
and then the post acute effect being
some kind of return to normalcy, but one
that is not totally complete, one that
still incorporates some of these newly
relaxed beliefs, these newly explored
beliefs.
Building on this rebus model, karin
Harris and colleagues last year proposed
this canal model of psychopathology,
which basically kind of takes the
intuition that the relaxation,
if the Reevis model is correct, if the
relaxation of beliefs has a therapeutic
outcome. If you kind of take that way of
thinking to its logical conclusion, you
might then propose something like this,
which would say if
relaxing overly strong beliefs
therapeutic, then having overly strong
beliefs in the first place is
pathological in some kind of way.
And they refer to this development
of these overly strongly represented
beliefs as canalized beliefs and
this problem generally as canalization
or this process of developing them as
canalization. And this is the canal
model of psych pathology. So they kind
of build on this idea,
this set of previous work in the
literature suggesting that there may be
some primary factor of psychopathology
and they suggest that this primary
factor is canalization. And in this work
they discuss a number of different
psychopathologies which seem to quite
clearly fit this canalization type
characterization. So it's very
relatively straightforward I think, to
understand things like addiction,
depression, anxiety disorders,
obsessive compulsive disorders. All of
these involve in one way or another
having some strongly held beliefs,
typically negative, negative beliefs in
the case of like, depression, anxiety,
obsessive compulsive, body image
disorder, or in the case of substance
use disorder, some very strong beliefs
about what kind of behaviors should be
taken at any given time in any given
context. And then
of course, the effect of psychedelics is
to undo canalization and
the better able any sort of therapeutic
intervention is to undo canalization,
the more likely for a positive
therapeutic outcome.
So I think this work has a lot of
strengths and there's a kind of elegance
to it. In our deep
Pinal's work that we've worked on,
we kind of identify a couple of
limitations of this canal model and
attempt to extend and refine the model
in ways that I think ultimately make it
more powerful, while kind of keeping the
essential elegant insight that
cannibalization is kind of like
intimately tied to pathology.
So the first kind of limitation I think
that we identify is that in
the canal model it's very heavily
implied that all forms of
canalization are pathological in one way
or another. And as I mentioned just now,
this is clearly the case for a large
class of very common psychopathologies.
It's when we start to look more towards
edge cases, I think that these
exceptions start to problematize this
understanding, right? So if we consider
psychopathologies such as bipolar,
borderline schizophrenia,
depersonalization disorder,
it becomes much more difficult to kind
of easily classify these as simply
problems of overly strong priors. In
many cases here we have problems of
priors that are not so strong or priors
that seem to drift over time in ways
that are problematic for both the
individual and the people that the
individual are close to. And if we
think about psychedelics then as being
this kind of panacea to undo
cannibalization and undo
psychopathology, we also run into this
other issue which is that there are
certain kinds of psychopathologies which
are typically issues
for use with psychedelics, right? So
schizophrenia being a very clear one,
where there's evidence of psychedelic
use being a trigger for the onset of
psychosis in individuals who are
predisposed to schizophrenia.
There's also evidence of the development
of depersonalization disorders with
strong psychedelic use. And this is not
what we would expect if psychedelics
were simply universally undoing
or getting rid of psychopathologies.
There's also this idea, which I think
Adam is going to develop quite a bit
later, that the stability of beliefs
is typically correlated with positive
mental health outcomes, not negative
ones. And what is a stable belief if not
one that is highly analyzed in some kind
of meaningful sense within the system?
And a second limitation is
that if you think about an actual
dynamical system, one that is
parameterized in some kind of meaningful
way, like a brain, which is
parameterized by synaptic connections
and then instantiates neural activity
patterns over time, and we think about
what kinds of optimization landscapes
are actually being induced by such a
system. We find that there's
not just one kind of canalization,
there's actually two kinds of
canalization. And in
our deep canals work, we attempt to kind
of take inspiration from deep learning
literature to tease apart these
two kinds of canalization and understand
them a bit more clearly. And they are
just to kind of give a preview these two
different things, overfitting and
plasticity loss. So overfitting is
the problem of your
canalized in a particular kind of way
and whatever sort of policy you've
learned, whatever sort of set of beliefs
you have, these don't generalize to some
other context. You're in context A,
you may be very well adapted, you move
to context B and whatever you've learned
doesn't apply there,
then plasticity loss is a little bit
different. Plasticity loss has to do
with not one's ability to generalize,
but rather one's ability to adapt or to
learn. So imagine you're in context A,
you may or may not be well adapted to
context A. If you move to context B,
the question becomes are you able to
adapt to context B or not? Not. Are you
immediately already ready to deal with
context B? But given time in context B,
can you learn and change?
And we use a very simple recurrent
neural network model to kind of make
sense of this. And I think this is
important because there can be different
kinds of canalization on these different
kinds of optimization landscapes and
these have unique implications for the
treatment of psychopathology. And I
think even more importantly,
psychedelics work on these different
landscapes in different ways. And so
understanding how they work is
essential to developing better drugs,
better treatment protocols and more
personalized treatment.
Okay, so what are these two optimization
landscapes? How can we make sense of
them? This is kind of like the
big overview figure of the deep canal's
work. So we kind of start with this
intuition of a recurrent neural network,
right? And in a recurrent neural network
there are these two sets of parameters
that you have at any given time. You
have the actual weights of the network
and then you have the hidden activation
of the network, right? And so the
weights of the network are theta and the
hidden activation is h and there's some
input into the network at any given time
step. And then the output of the network
is a function of both the input and the
hidden state. And the hidden state is
updated at every time the hidden
activation pattern. And this gives us
essentially these two different
landscapes. One, what we refer to as the
inference landscape or the type A
landscape. And this is equivalent to the
neural activation pattern of a brain at
any time. So what gets read off from an
fMRI, what gets read off from the EEG is
going to correspond to this activity
landscape, but kind of like underlying
or supporting this activity landscape is
this other more fundamental landscape
which is the actual optimization
landscape that is induced by the
synaptic weights themselves.
And this is what is the result of
right click synaptic connectivity in the
brain between all the sets of neurons in
the brain. This is what is changing when
we have various forms of heavy and
plasticity heavy in learning.
And this is what kind of instantiates
the possible sets of neural activity
patterns, right? So this is kind of like
a way we can start to understand this,
which is when we think about belief
landscapes, right? As I mentioned
before, here's a very simple diagram
where we have a two dimensional belief
landscape. And let's say there's someone
who's depressed or potentially depressed
and they might have a negative self
image. I'm a terrible person, I can't do
anything right. Something like this.
This would be encoded as a particular
position in this belief landscape.
When the neural activity pattern looks
like this, this belief is what gets
expressed, right? And there's
another set of neural activity patterns
which would correspond to a positive
self image, a positive self belief, I'm
great, I'm wonderful, or even just, I'm
okay, I'm totally acceptable as a
person. And this would be a different
set of patterns. So based
on the synaptic, the actual connectivity
structure of the brain, these two
patterns may be more or less likely. So
here these are being represented by
these two different sets of
neural activation landscapes which are
the result of two different positions in
this synaptic weight landscape space.
And in this top space, the one
that's in the middle of here that then
is represented here at the top of part C
of the figure, we see that there's very
high precision assigned to or very high
likelihood assigned to the negative self
image and very low likelihood here
assigned to the positive self image.
But in some other part of the synaptic
weight landscape, a very different kind
of neural activity landscape might be
instantiated. And this one kind of has
the inverse properties where negative
self image is unlikely and positive self
image is much more likely. So we can
kind of then understand positions in
the neural activity landscape as kind of
corresponding to specific
phenomenological experiential
instantiations of certain kinds of
beliefs, right? So like the actual
experience of holding a negative self
image or holding a positive self image.
And we can understand positions in the
synaptic weight landscape as being
something more general. So in the case
of depression, there might be a specific
set of synaptic weight connectivity
which would correspond to what you
might call a depressed individual,
someone who might qualify as having
major depressive disorder and another
set of synaptic weights connectivity
pattern that wouldn't qualify as that.
Okay, so before I get into the
psychedelic, how psychedelics relate to
this, I think Adam is going to talk a
little bit about some work he's done
extending the.
Hello. So,
yeah, I've been thinking about this
a while and then along the way I
met Arthur, who also has been thinking
about this a while, but in different
ways. And so like
Arthur's background is in basically
consciousness science and a very
peculiar field of computational
consciousness science in terms of actual
models of what it would be to have a
conscious system, even potentially an
artificially conscious system. And so
I'm coming from more free energy
principle and active inference, my
background and Arthur's coming from more
mainstream machine learning. And so we
were coming together to explore this
beast from different perspectives and
been finding a lot of, I think, very
interesting overlap. And so in terms of
Albus, the basic idea is to take Rebus
and expand on it. I love rebus.
It's a great framework and I've been
trying to make it, I guess, more
flexible in terms of being able to
handle a wider range of assumptions. So
not just talking about relaxed beliefs,
but also potentially strengthened
beliefs and in different combinations.
This was always part of the rebus
framework. And that you can have all
sorts of both direct and indirect
effects. When you're dealing with a
large predictive hierarchy or any
complex system, you change something in
one way, but then you'll get an effect
elsewhere. So if you have this hierarchy
of predictions, for instance, you can
potentially relax beliefs at higher
levels and that can indirectly cause
strengthened beliefs at lower levels.
So you can both get relaxed and
strengthened beliefs and psychedelics
and all sorts of different combinations.
And so with Albus the
idea is so I've been calling as opposed
to a belief relaxation. When you get
this sort of basically bottom
right here, you might see it. So this
red would be basically something
like a synchronized complex of neural
activity, often involving the thalamus,
which would be thought to encode your
predictions, or your top down stream of
priors, which then are suppressing the
ascending stream of prediction errors.
And so under revis, you're seeing here
relaxed predictions, a smaller complex
of synchronized activity. And the gates
are down. Just like Arthur described,
more things are coming in. Rebus will
sometimes be described in terms of so
when we're talking about rebus this idea
of relaxing beliefs. We're thinking at
the functional or computational level,
like with David Mars and analyzing the
mind, you have these three, I suppose,
Supervenient levels. They're compatible
and synergistic. So computational
functional, like abstractly, what is
the system doing? Something like the
pseudocode of the system and then
implementational mechanistically how
it's realized and then in the middle,
some sort of algorithmic intermediate
abstraction layer. How are these
computations realized via these
mechanisms? Some bridging. Principle
description. And so when it comes to
rebus, you can adopt it in different
ways and relate to it differently. So
you can relate to it at the functional
level or you can relate to it at the
algorithmic or implementational levels
in terms of where you're taking the
account. So, for instance, you might
think something like rebus effects is a
very valuable model of something like
what they call quantum change of
psychedelics. But you don't necessarily
believe in predictive processing, but
you still might be, you could say like a
rebus type theorist. Or you might be
thinking in terms of rebus in a more
narrow sense of thinking, of predictive
processing information flows, but then
when you get to the overall person and
integrated organism and the agent, you
might have different interpretations
there. So with the work with Albus,
basically the idea would be to take
predictive processing and models
of psychedelic action and suggest that
sometimes not only do
we have these relaxation of belief
landscapes, but we might have the
opposite of strengthening. And so
specifically, if you're activating these
five HD two A neurons, which would be at
the deeper levels of the cortical sheet
and also the deeper levels of the
cortical hierarchy, more inwards and
higher up, and these would be the units
that would loop to the thalamus and
thereby be able to form large
synchronous integrated complexes.
But that when you excite them too much,
they don't wait for each other to sync
up, they fire whenever they can out of
sync. And this relaxes the belief
landscape. However, it's not clear this
should happen the whole way through for
any amount of increasing the gain on
these neurons. So in theory, just
increasing the gain a little bit,
unless that might help them to sync up,
that might strengthen the belief,
whether it's a situationally specific
suggestion of you in this context or
maybe something old coming to the
surface and if you will manifesting.
So Albus basically, in a nutshell,
would be saying to take rebus and keep
going with it and look for different
combinations of both strengthened,
both directly and indirectly
strengthened and relaxed beliefs.
That's basically it. And so I'm not
going to go into too many more details.
Arthur and I just submitted this for
publication. Wish us luck. Hopefully the
reviewers will be useful,
maybe even kind, but preferably useful,
and kick it back to Arthur.
But before work,
I think it's immensely important that we
get these details, right? These are
extremely powerful medicines that could
revolutionize things or we could have a
backlash if we do it wrong, if we're
careless, if we don't see the risks,
but also if we're overly beholden to a
single way of viewing things
prematurely, we might also miss
opportunities to help, potentially
enormous opportunities. For instance,
you might not think of helping people,
for instance, micro dosing for cognitive
decline. You might not have thought of
that and that might be a really big deal
that you do think of that. So I guess
for going back to Arthur, one more thing
would be just in terms of, at least for
me, experientially. The way I sometimes
think of it is with relation
to well being and suffering,
both things matter, like the strength of
your positive beliefs and the strength
of your negative beliefs. And sometimes
the negative beliefs have positive
aspects and vice versa. So it's both
like you might relax your beliefs and to
use like a Harry Potter metaphor be
somewhat so much out of the grip of the
dementors that usually that under some
circumstances might be pursuing you that
you have room to be different, to become
different, to think different things
under this different state. But
additionally, and not mutually
exclusively, not necessarily
incompatibly maybe synergistically the
strength of what beliefs you're able to
have in that moment and maybe draw upon
from the past could be deeply important.
Your values, the kinds of beliefs that
you call upon in times of need and they
give you hope. Maybe those are just
originally suggested to you right there
in the session. But maybe there's
something else, another belief, and that
strengthening it could be a good thing.
And even without a clinical context,
like microdosers, for instance, it's not
clear exactly they're trying to relax
their beliefs, like the range of use
cases, the way we want to relate them
and how we want to be in the world. It
seems complicated to me. So I will take
it back to Arthur.
Great. Yeah. Thanks so much, Adam. OK,
so with that context of Alice, I want to
talk a little bit about how we might
understand at a very high level what
psychedelics are doing to these two
belief landscapes. So before I showed
you very quickly, I guess I can go back
to it. In the Rebus model there's only
one type of optimization landscape and
so there's only one type of canalization
and what is supposed to be happening is
a relaxation of leaves which is
strong during the acute effect and
persists in the post acute effect.
So with albus though, we might be able
to think about all of this a little bit
differently. We can, enduring the
acute effects of psychedelics,
interpret what's happening to the type A
landscape as being less of a kind of
universal relaxation and more of a kind
of destabilization where under certain
circumstances beliefs are being
strengthened, other beliefs. Are being
relaxed. This is changing quite rapidly
over the course of time. So a
certain belief might be transiently
strengthened a few minutes later, it may
no longer be supported or supportable.
And this actually functionally enables a
kind of exploration of a wide space
of belief instantiations during the
acute effects of the drug.
As far as the inference landscape is
concerned, post acute effects, as Adam
was saying, it could be the fact that
certain positive beliefs are explored
and can be strengthened, other negative
beliefs might be weakened. This is kind
of like the ideal psychotherapeutic
outcome. It may be on
average that something like a
relaxation, a general relaxation of
beliefs is what you might see. But the
way that you get there is likely going
to be through a kind of much more
complicated process, I think. What's
then interesting and related also to
what Adam said about thinking much more
broadly about how psychedelics might be
used in terms of neurocognitive
disorders, in addition to kind of like
traditional psychopathologies is to
think about what's happening to the
learning landscape, the kind of like
underlying synaptic weight landscape.
And what do we understand is happening
here kind of quite clearly is there is
neurogenesis psychoplastogenic effects,
there's dendritic growth. And what is
this enabling? Well, this is enabling
greater connectivity between, within and
between networks. And so kind of from a
functional learning perspective,
learning theory perspective, what this
means is that gradient information can
flow more easily through these networks.
And what this means is that it's easier
to get from one part of the network to
the other part of the network. There are
fewer of these kind of optimization
local minima, there are fewer of these
kind of tricky saddle points.
And what this means kind of like
functionally is that this plasticity
loss that I discussed earlier is going
to be less of an issue. And here it
seems to be kind of like regardless of
the acute, the actual phenomenological
effects, there are very strong
downstream effects on this structural
connectivity. And I think there's some
interesting work suggesting that there
may actually be independent mechanisms
that are affecting these two landscapes.
So there's recent work suggesting for
example that psychedelics as well as
ketamine is able to kind of particularly
bind to receptors in the brain that
produce that result in the kind of
release of the brain derived
neurotrophic factor and then the
downstream changes in synaptic weighting
and that this may be potentially totally
independent of the five H C two a
agonism. Right?
And this has very interesting
implications for future drug design and
development. Okay,
so I'm going to, before my next slide,
turn it over to Adam once more to
briefly talk a bit about personality
theory and the relationship between
psychedelics and.
Hello again.
So for the past few years I've been
doing some work with a personality
researcher, Colin de Jung, on
intersections between the way agency is
modeled in the free energy principle and
active inference framework and the way
that persons are considered in different
situations in personality science and
looking for points of intersection.
Personality is actually an extremely
deep concept. And if you think of it,
I guess we call it like the normal form
of a system in terms of what is
the way you can describe the most of the
system with like the minimal message
length, the account for the most of the
least. And what we're trying to account
for is the states that people tend to
occupy, people aren't always happy,
people aren't always sad, people aren't
always friendly, they're not always
angry. It's all sorts of things that
there's a range that people are
encountering but they tend to occupy
some states more than others. And you
might call that their personality and
you might call it many systems would
have their own personalities in terms of
trying to describe something like their
essence and so they're attracting
states. And so with Colin de Jung's
work, he interprets personality and
these major domains of personality that
people have discovered a reliable factor
structure ways you can chunk the
variance, the big five as a trait
hierarchy but where these different
traits are interpreted as cybernetic
control parameters. Specifically
cybernetics in terms of the study of
goal seeking systems governed by various
forms of feedback that different stages
of the process of pursuing goals,
evaluating outcomes updating
understanding that basically the
personality as different modes of being
in the world. For cybernetic systems,
interpreting them as parameters for goal
pursuit because we are goal seeking
systems trying to pursue the goals we
value. And so I
guess moving to this with relation to
what we're talking about now, both in
terms of personality formation,
reformation and the structure of
personality.
To. Get to the P factor within
personality theory, this big five
traits, the set of big five traits,
there's a richer or more detailed factor
structure, a hierarchical structure for
personality that's been discovered. So
above the Big Five, neuroticism,
agreeableness, conscientiousness,
you'll have a metatrate of their shared
various that's observed called
stability. It's also been called alpha
by, I think, Digman. And then above the
traits of extroversion and openness
intellect, you have this MetaTrade of
plasticity and are called beta and
the shared variants of these two. So
what's interesting is that within this
field of within high top, which is this
effort to try to characterize
psychopathology using the same kind of
data driven methods in personality
science. A principled account of the
structure of psychopathology, the way
that personality has a structure and
trying to account for this, there seems
to be a common factor across
many forms of psychopathology that's
referred to as the P factor and it tends
to be the inverse of stability. It's
high neuroticism, low agreeableness and
low conscientiousness. And this is
actually what's
referred to in the article as this P
factor, thinking of it as a
lack of flexibility. You could make a
case for it. But more straightforwardly
it seems to be a lack of stability. For
something to be a lack of flexibility
you would maybe be thinking of something
more like plasticity, like someone
having low plasticity. But empirically
that's not what's observed. And so if
empirically that's not what's observed,
that's a very important detail we should
stop and take note of. So you might say
that rather than emphasizing the first
principal component of psychopathology,
it's possible that this Canal model is
actually focusing on the second factor.
It's not a contest. It's still
enormously a big factor like the work of
Stephen Hayes and others showing that a
lack of flexibility is transdiagnostic.
But just empirically speaking, the first
principal component of psychopathology
might be more closely related to a lack
of stability rather than insufficient
plasticity. I guess
one more thing to think of in terms of
stability and like as it's
not exactly a contest, they're both
important, both need to be considered
and they're deeply interrelated. So
Colin describes them as being in a state
of something like dynamic tension. Like
if you're insufficiently plastic and
inflexible, you're not going to stay
stable for long in a changing world,
but if you don't have a stable base to
move from, it's going to be hard to be
plastic and reconfigure yourself in a
sustainable way either. However, you
could also see someone being overly
rigid and excessive stability in a way
that undermines their plasticity or
overly flexible in a way that basically
is destabilizing. So a dynamic tension
but involving synergies also.
And I think in terms of the structure of
personality and well being, this is what
we need to keep in mind that both are
needed, stability and plasticity. And
this is also just within it's
actually what this was inspired, I think
in Colin's thinking to consider these
metatrades this way from machine
learning, I think actually reading
Grossberg and Stability plasticity trade
offs and that's why he interpreted these
metatrades in those terms. So I guess
one more thing is there
is a Petersonian backstory here that I
don't know if I want to get into, but we
can discuss it later if there's yeah,
back to Arthur.
That was great. Thanks. Adams yeah,
very, very helpful context which should
hopefully make this slide here much more
clear to everyone.
So given these kind of, like, two meta
traits, stability and plasticity,
which, as Adam beautifully described
you're in this kind of dynamic tension
with one another, we can kind of
go back to these two optimization
landscapes and these machine learning
concepts that I discussed earlier and
couldn't try to understand how these
things might all relate and ultimately
relate to psychopathology. So I had
hinted before that there were
these kind of two types of
cannibalization. We might say one being
overfitting and another being plasticity
loss. And we can interpret these as kind
of like being extremes, the kind of like
canalized end of how these two
optimization landscapes might manifest.
So in the type A inference landscape,
this looks like overfitting on one end,
heavy canalization and underfitting on
the other end in the machine learning
context, right? So overfitting being
having very strong rigid beliefs that
are in a particular environmental
context, adaptive, but are very unlikely
to be adapted in any other context,
underfitting being having a set of
beliefs which are not adapted to the
current context and also unlikely to be
adapted to any other context.
As far as stability is concerned, I
think we can understand stability, this
MetaTrade, as kind of representing the
balance of these two things, right? You
have high stability when you are either
overfit to a particular context or
underfit. So this means you're well fit
to this context that you're in now and
you're also likely to be well fit to
other future contacts. I think this is
also in complexity science, sometimes
described as metastability, right? So
you're at a stable point that will also
likely be able to take you to other
stable points in the future. And this
kind of like ability to stay stable over
time is then stability MetaTrade.
We can then look at the type B, the
learning landscape, where the kind of
extreme version of canalization is this
plasticity loss where it's very
difficult to adapt to new contexts.
The inverse of this is then catastrophic
forgetting, where the problem is not one
of adapting to new contexts, the problem
is one of meaningfully retaining
adaptive strategies and beliefs from
previous contexts.
And so obviously neither of these are
desirable.
What is desirable is some kind of
balance between these two or one is able
to adapt just enough to new context
without forgetting previously learned
things. But here the relationship to the
Mediterranean plasticity is a bit
different than stability, right? So as
is being represented on this graph, the
more plastic you are, basically the less
canalized you are in the space, the more
easy it is to move around. But actually
extreme versions of this end up
manifesting as catastrophic forgetting,
at least in the machine learning
context. And I think this in particular
has relevance for psychopathology
and relevance for this idea,
maybe complicates this idea, right,
that psychedelic therapy is
in and of itself likely to always lead
to positive outcomes.
Okay? And we can attempt to understand
this by making an effort
at trying to map or understand various
forms of psychology in the context of
these two different learning landscapes.
And so before I get into this too much,
I think it's important to say that this
is very much a kind of like preliminary
and provisional attempt at making sense
of these things. I hope that this is
kind of the start of a much more
fleshed out dialogue looking at how we
can kind of understand psychopathology
with respect to machine learning
concepts. But I think this at least
gives a good starting point for maybe
trying to understand where and why
psychedelic therapy is useful, isn't
useful,
which is a bit more nuanced than this
simple idea of like psychopathology
means cannibalization and psychedelic
therapy means reducing cannibalization.
Right? Okay, so let's try to
make sense of this a little bit. So for
the kind of classic set of
psychopathologies for which there has
been a lot of great research done with
psychedelic therapy and a lot of clear
benefit has been seen. I think we can
kind of class these within this upper
left hand corner here, where these are
disorders of both overfitting, which
means in the moment overly strong
beliefs get represented. These are
strong attractor points in the neural
activation landscape and plasticity
loss in the type B landscape. Which
means that not only is a certain kind of
dynamics instantiated, which make, for
example, in the case of major depressive
disorder, extremely negative self
evaluations very common, but it's the
case that even given the correct changes
in environmental context. Even given in
the case of psychedelic cystotherapy, a
lot of the work with major depressive
disorder is being done with treatment
resistant depression, right? And what is
treatment resistant depression but a
kind of a set of beliefs, a set of
neural activity patterns which are
resistant to adaptation, to new
environmental contexts being whatever
sort of psychotherapy or previous drug
was used. So this is high plasticity
loss, high overhead and rate and
these are kind of fortunately for
psychedelic therapy and I think maybe
for psychiatry in general, these are all
very common and very, very costly
psychopathologies. Right? So if it is
the case that psychedelic therapy can
treat these effectively, that's
fantastic. But I think we can maybe look
at a more complicated if we start to
expand to other psychopathologies, the
story becomes a little bit more
complicated. Right? So we can look at
the bottom left hand corner here where
we have cases of in the inference
landscape still overfitting, but in
the learning landscape something else
happening, form of kind of catastrophic
forgetting or a form of kind of drift of
the belief landscape that's being
instantiated here. Right? So I think two
kind of representative pathologies here
typically referred to as some form of
bipolar disorder or some form of
borderline personality disorder. So in
both of these cases, in the moment to
moment neural activity as it unfolds,
there are very strong sets of beliefs
being instantiated at any given time and
these are very difficult to change.
Right? But the key differentiating
point here being that over longer
timescales, over the timescales of days
or weeks, the kinds of beliefs that are
instantiated change quite a lot. Right?
So someone who's bipolar, if they're in
a manic episode or in a depressive
episode, the nature of the belief
landscape being instantiated is very
different for borderline individuals
from a daily or weekly basis, the nature
of one's beliefs about the people that
are close to them can change very
rapidly, very extremely in certain
cases. And so here the
benefit of psychedelic therapy is a bit
more mixed where there is likely the
case that to the extent to which the
kind of overt type A beliefs can be
updated and changed to be more positive,
be hopefully more relaxed, that's
positive. But to the extent to which
plasticity may be being increased when
it's not actually needed, when there's
not actually meaningful therapeutic
benefits of that, it's a bit
questionable. I think there's clear
borderline, or rather bipolar for
example, is often individuals with
bipolar are often excluded from
psychedelic trials under
the assumption for example, that
psychedelics may trigger a manic episode
or may trigger psychosis. And I think
that is a valid concern.
So on kind of that topic then, this
bottom right hand corner would be cases
of both underfooting and catastrophic
forgetting with I think schizophrenia
being kind of like the most clear
manifestation of this.
And here there's very little work
currently looking at trying to treat
schizophrenia with psychedelic therapy.
I think for pretty good reasons though
I would say to the
extent to which there are secondary
manifestations, secondary issues like
depression, anxiety that people with
schizophrenia might have, these actually
may be treatable with some form of
psychedelic therapy. And then lastly,
this upper right hand corner here would
correspond to underfitting in the type A
landscape along with plasticity loss.
So I think a good example of this is
something like ADHD, where there are not
very particularly strong beliefs that
are being instantiated at any given
time, but it's
difficult to change these set of
beliefs. Nonetheless, I think here
there's a case where it's not totally
clear how the benefit will actually play
out in both of these cases. I've heard
interesting work around like microdosing
may be of interest.
I think yeah, more research has to be
done to be seen. Right, and then what
would microdosing be doing? Right,
microdosing would be very slowly kind of
like decreasing plasticity loss just a
little bit, potentially also decreasing
underfitting, as Adam has kind of
suggested in the Albus model.
And here we have just kind of like a
brief overview of more or less
everything I've described about how
these two landscapes are different. I
think most of these things I've said
before pretty clearly right so the type
A landscape corresponds
to the neural activity pattern. This is
the hidden state of the RNN.
Overcannilization is going to be
stereotyped mental circuits, very
strongly held beliefs. Under
canalization is going to be these
inconsistently deployed circuits.
It looks like overfitting in the
canalized case, underfitting in the non
canalized case going to correspond to
stability, the metatrate. I hadn't
discussed this before, but I think
there's a relationship between cognitive
flexibility and this inference landscape
psychedelics are mainly going to affect
the work at the acute level care.
And this is by directly exciting the
neurons or inducing forms of hadavian
plasticity and the outcome is going to
be a mixture of relaxation and
strengthening of the kind that Adam
described in the Albus case. The type B
landscape then is working on the
synaptic weights and these are the
actual network parameters in our RNN
model. Over canalization is this
inability to learn or adapt over time.
Under canalization is the inability to
retain information right? And those
correspond to plasticity loss and
catastrophic forgetting. This also is
kind of the traditional plasticity
metatrate, which I think corresponds to
this longer term constructed
psychological flexibility. The effects
are going to mainly be mediated post
acutely with psychedelics and these are
the more downstream metaplastic effects,
the psychoplastogenic effects.
And I think on the whole the effect here
is a relaxation of canalization.
And yeah, these are just the references.
So those are the slides I have that's
kind of the overview of the Deep canals
model, I think. Now I'll turn
it over to Mike who's going to share
some thoughts both about this work and
some of his own work and kind of this
approach to understanding psychedelics
more broadly.
Ah, great. Yeah, thank you for that
overview. That was great.
So I guess I'm just in general very
optimistic about this corner of
neuroscience, that there are these very
intuitive models that are very sort of
clinically significant and I
also think there is a lot
of responsibility to sort of get things
right here as well. As Adam noted.
I have just a few comments and for
the viewers, I'm not speaking for Arthur
and Adam, I'm just grateful for the
invitation to join the discussion.
So I wanted to note quickly
three research themes dealing with the
implementation of this class of model.
So just broadly kind of pointing at both
Deep Canals and Andrebus and Albus.
So in 2019
I wrote Neural Annealing and that was
sort of developing the canalization
frame within the context of energy
buildup in the eigen modes of a system.
So you have the nice annealing
metaphor, you have a temperature
parameter and entropic disintegration.
Robin Carter said a beautiful paper on
that dantropic brain
and then you sort of have
a post heating result where
the microstructure of your system is
sort of a result of how
hot and how long the heating was.
So it's an alternative take on belief
relaxation. And I do think that there
are some pluses in terms of sort of
explicitly making the annealing
metaphor. And I
think that two things that I'd point
out. One, top down models or top down
predictive models as energy sinks and
eigen modes as the places where energy
can build up or almost sort of hide from
top down models. So you get
this phenomenon of semantically neutral
energy or semantically illegible energy
we can say, which is sort of
kind of how perhaps
psychedelics music and meditation all
sort of allow energy building. The
energy that they contribute to the
system can evade the top tone models.
And yeah, just to note, one item that
I'm looking at now is what is Deep
Canals? Has the inference landscape
versus learning landscape distinction?
And how would one sort of build
that distinction within the neural
Annealing framework? And guess one
metaphor that I'm considering is the
self as sort of a magnet to sort
of apply a
constraint, a uniform focusing
constraint on the system as it's
cooling. The second item
that I wanted to mention, so I have this
piece, autism as a disorder of
dimensionality. And this brings in
the concept of network density that it
may very well be that people on the
spectrum have literally more neurons and
or more synapses. And there's this great
Michelangelo quote, I saw the angel in
the stone, and I set him free.
And sort of the thicker networks you
have, the more stone you have to work
with, but you actually have to do the
work. So you
sort of have to do sort of well,
normally you sort of inherit these
highly pretrained optimized circuits,
almost like asics application specific
integrated circuit.
And then this is kind of more an
untrained network, and you have to train
it yourself. And within the Deep Canals
framework, this would show up as both
underfitting and higher capacity for
plasticity.
So I think that's going to be an
interesting thread to pull.
Finally. So I just posted that last
week, principles of Vaso Computation and
as an implementation level account of
active inference. And this is a big
rabbit hole. I don't think we have time
to go down it today. But I
just comment that I really like the way
Deep Canals explicitly splits out the
learning landscape and the inference
landscape, that I think that making this
distinction is increasingly going to
make sense.
Back to Arthur. Yeah, awesome.
Well, thank you all for the
presentations. Arthur and Adam, feel
free to pick up where Michael left off,
or I can bring in some questions from
the chat or from what I've written down.
Just a quick comment. I do think that in
the Deep Canals framework, it's going to
be interesting to sort of look into
metabolic demands, and sort of different
metabolic disorders are pretty hot in
brain science right now. And I do think
that it'll be interesting to look at
sort of what the metabolic profile is in
terms of each of the four items in the
quadrant, if one
quadrant or another quadrant is
particularly associated with more
metabolic demands in the system.
Arthur yeah.
No, that's fascinating. I'd love
to kind of hear a little bit more about
this comment you made about the salt as
a magnet that's applying these
constraints. Oh,
yeah. So there's the,
like, psychedelics the the effects are
not or sort of the you
sort of get pulled back into position
after after some time.
And I
can't say that this is a full theory at
this point, but in the neuroscience
notation 2018, I talked
about the self as kind
of the god of the gaps in terms of
aligning different scales.
You have circuits which kind of pull in
different ways and you have the
mesoscale systems which pull in
different ways and you have the overall
brain wide systems that pull in
different ways. And kind of the self is
sort of the thing that tries to make
everything work together.
And an alternate frame would
be sort of this alpha is just kind
of this slow gravity toward
disalignment.
Yeah, I don't have anything particularly
more to share.
Yeah, that makes sense. It's
interesting. Well to combine the heating
up and the magnetism, different metals
and connections there to alchemy and
everything different metals when heated
up and cooled down in specific ways
change their magnetic profile. So of
course this is all just concordances but
they're very interesting. And then also
to the metabolic angle that
reminded me of the trilogy by Dale
Pendel with Pharmaconosis and
the other two books where treated
alongside traditional psychoactives we
could say like caffeine and nicotine and
some of the other substances that were
mentioned here. Also there's tea,
sugar and these are treated as
psychedelic or at least as in the same
pantheon of neurocognitive modifying in
the sense that the destinies of
individuals and of empires ride
on the sense making and decision making
influence of sugar, for example.
So it definitely broadens our
perspective to include the so called
classical molecules like LSD.
But also maybe we could think more
broadly about antioxidants or about
different lipids or about different
metabolic connections.
Michael Pollan's recent book this is
Your Mind on plants I think it kind of
has that what you're saying in mind
because it includes caffeine, not
introduces a psychedelic but just
discussed among also psychedelics. I
think I remember he focuses on masculine
but it is a different
way of being in the world, potentially
radically different like if caffeine is
in your life or it is not, it's a
different life world. And different
extended niche. I'll go to
a question in the live chat so anyone
can give a thought. So Matt asks
is there any way how to approach the
individual reactions to psychedelics in
terms of positive or negative results of
treatment using the ideas of deep
canals? So how can we approach
predictions and explanations at the
individual scale with
what you're sharing today?
One thing for this
is kind of like a meta comment, but if
we're actually going to do computational
psychiatry and we actually are going to
and precision medicine so the goal being
to create models of sufficient detail
that they could actually guide our
practice and guide our practice in a way
where we know for an individual what
they might need in any given context.
So precision medicine with respect to
standard antidepressants people,
sometimes they'll go for a long time
before they find ones that work, and
sometimes things are made worse, and
then they might deal with antidepressant
withdrawal if they're looking for the
right one, and if they're in a state of
acute distress, that could be a hard
lot. And so if you can help to speed up
that process of finding what works and
what might hurt also to avoid that, the
ability to help people is immense. And
so for that so the
meta comment is I have to just say I'm
not convinced that an act of inference.
We're doing the job. I think we're not
acknowledging our uncertainty and I
think the models are under specified
with respect to the complexity of the
effects we would expect on different
scales and in characterizing the systems
and we need to be more patient and
modest. But what we don't know before we
go on rushing in headlong into telling
the rest of psychiatry how they should
comport themselves and what models they
should use based on psychedelic science.
And plausible models, hopeful models,
but very early days. And with the
reality being complex in the ways we're
seeing here, this was not an easy set of
lectures or a set of talks like what we
were going through. And, yeah, if we're
actually going to be able to handle
these powerful medicines responsibly,
we got to go into the weeds. The one
more meta comment was like I think I saw
someone say how can something like help
everything? I don't know if this is
right but it's almost like a violation
of no free lunch theorems or something.
It's like how could something just be
good across the board without something
is off? You've calculated wrong
somewhere you had to pay the price
either in some trade off that wasn't
acknowledged. But that being said there
are some things which are generally good
for a lot of things like being more
flexible.
If you can get something like
metastability I
think I'm a church member of the I'm a
faithful member of the church of
criticality. I think Mark Miller might
have indoctrinated me with optimal grips
but basically like the ability to have
an optimal grip on existence in your
soul, not too tight, not too loose and
being able to move around and be
flexible in itinerants. Something kind
of like mindfulness is just like
sriracha for the soul. It's good for
everything almost you just put on this,
put it on, that makes it better.
I buy that there might be some things
that are good across the board but I
wouldn't call though psychedelics
necessarily putting you in this state of
optimal criticality or anything in
general. The rhetoric I'm uncomfortable
with of saying psychedelics do X. I
would prefer to say which psychedelic.
Psychedelics tend to do x but just a
little more qualifier like not weasel
words but just like a little bit more
like this psychedelic
might do x in this context with this
dose in this sentence setting but that
being said there do also though seem to
be across. The board, broad,
sweeping, not super, but overarching
statements that we can make that express
a lot with a little. And so I don't want
to be so much of a splitter and a
prickly person finding all the details
that these powerful things we can
basically give to people to guide our
research. I don't want to leave that on
table either. I guess that's a
bunch of meta level commentary that did
not address the thing.
I think that's useful. That's very
helpful. I think to have all that
context. With respect to the question
itself, I would maybe offer this, which
might be helpful, which know, I think
you mentioned it, Adam, and it's very
frequently mentioned this idea of set
and setting, right. As being heavily
predictive of the quality of the acute
psychedelic experience, and often also,
to some extent, the quality of the post
acute experience. And I think we can
understand this in the deep canals
model, quite straightforwardly.
So I'll just quickly pull back up one
of these slides here. Yeah.
Right. So what is set and setting?
So set is mindset, which would
basically be some combination of your
current position in the synaptic weight
landscape and the current state of your
neural activation landscape. Right. So
your place in both landscapes is your
mindset, and the setting is
what is generating this input. Right.
What is generating the x into the
network. And that's some complicated
function of the environment. And then we
can understand the evolution of movement
through the inference landscape during
the acute effects of the drug as then
kind of like very directly and
straightforwardly being a function of
these two things. Right. Because both of
these things are basically what's
affecting how this landscape evolves
over time and how you move through the
landscape. And so with
this in mind, I guess we can then start
to characterize and think about, okay,
well, what kinds of we
can maybe be a little bit more
mechanistic about how does input
from the environment, the setting,
actually, given that we relatively fix
the actual synaptic weight landscape,
how is that changing the dynamics over
time or the other way around? Right?
Like, how is fixing the input,
the environmental context relatively
stable and looking at individuals who
are at different fixed points, at
different points of time, going to
change the dynamics of the event?
Right. And I think given that this is a
highly stochastic process, given that
these dynamics of albus are at play
right. Where certain beliefs are being
strengthened, other beliefs are being
relaxed, I think
at least having this hold on, okay,
well, set and setting is really
important. And it's important because
these are explicitly conditioning the
way in which both the landscape,
the inference landscape is shaped and
how you move around it and how it's
being dynamically perturbed.
Yeah, hopefully that answers a little
bit the question.
Nice. I just want to
jump in there, just thinking about
biomarkers if
we're looking for something that's of
high clinical specificity, we want to
sort of be able to measure what's going
on in
a very careful way. So first of all,
what is temperature parameter?
We talk about, okay, psychedelics
increase the temperature parameter. But
how high? And do different substances
and dosages sort of differ in
interesting ways? Probably, yes. And
then also sort of measuring temperature
parameter, measuring the temperature
parameter in different parts of the
body. So you might have a different
temperature, like not literal
temperature, but computational entropic
integration in different parts of your
body and also the
plasticity status in different networks
throughout your body. So I guess I
see a big frontier here as
thinking some doing some careful
thinking around biomarkers and
proxies and inferring these sort of
things that we are talking about as core
and I think they are core and we should
be able to find good marks for them.
Yeah, that's totally correct. And yeah,
I just want to repeat it for my own sake
even. Right, which is that these two
things which I think were maybe one is I
think already a core part of the deep
canals work right. Which is that I was
showing these single images of these toy
optimization landscapes. But of course,
the human being, the nervous system has
multiple many of these landscapes
hierarchically organized, right? And
they influence each other in a
complicated way. And the
project forward is to understand where
these landscapes are, what they look
like and how we can find biomarkers to
them and begin. If these two kinds of
characterizations are true, this
overfitting underfitting plasticity loss
and catastrophic forgetting,
then it's a very meaningful project to
be able to quantify that objectively
somehow an individual. And that's when
you can start to get to this point that
Ada was talking about of precision
medicine and understanding like okay,
well, actually it turns out like these
networks are catalyzed in this kind of
way. And because of that we can say with
much more certainty that this kind of
psychedelic intervention is going to
likely be helpful.
I don't know if this potentially brings
in some of the work with vascular
and neurovascular and
visceral integration that you're doing.
So there's like a sense in the free
energy principle where the overall
phenotype and extended phenotype
in terms of its constructing and
coupling within constructing its
Econiche, its success in manifesting
this phenotype there is one
free energy functional for this overall
effort as a kind of prediction that's
enacted through the dynamics. But you
could also break it down in terms of
subsystems with local gradients and
local autopoietic processes that are in
like they're brought together into an
overall system, hopefully with synergies
and they have to be to be an organism
and an agent. And we call this like a
thing to the extent it has thingness.
It's coming together. I guess think of
maybe like energy landscape, something
like let's just say right now, in this
moment, my explicitly felt beliefs.
But my body also though might have a
different opinion, different parts of
it, in terms of what it's implicitly
optimizing its revealed preference from
its inaction that may or may not
correspond to how I feel about it. It
might be difference of opinion. I might
not even be tuning in. I might be
ignoring it maybe because I don't want
to. And so it's kind of like the score
kept by the body might have its own be
describable as its own information
geometry which is being tracked to
degrees and is in different degrees of
alignment with different ones at
different levels of a control hierarchy.
So plausible?
Absolutely, I think so,
yeah. I think of
the body as sort of a parliament of
different networks. And alignment
is the scarce resource. Coordination is
always the scarce resource. And how does
the body keep alignment and when does it
go wrong too? And I guess I see
this as sort of harmonically mediated.
Each part of the body has some choice of
what else in the body to listen to. And
depending on the particular sort of
location in the information topology,
different parts of the body have
different carrots and sticks by which to
try to control other parts of the body.
So if your stomach is very unhappy,
it's going to start grumbling and then
it'll let the body know, okay, I need
some food, I really seriously need
some food. And then the rest
of the body, they can sort of turn away
from it and then it'll just get louder
and then you have to turn it away from
it more and it'll get louder. And that's
of course a negative dynamic. If it gets
what it wants, maybe it sort of gives a
very harmonious uh and
sort of tries to give carriage the rest
of the I just uh there's
an ecosystem there.
I'll go to another question in the live
chat. So Bert asks what
do you think of the average of solving
within a generative hierarchy and the
impact of temporary openness moving it
upwards? And then I asked to clarify
what do you mean the average of solving?
And Bert wrote where predictions meet
incoming signals like discussed in
Rebus, where top down predictions are
softened in precision and thus solved.
For.
I think Arthur will be able to get into
the details of that better than I
would. But one thing I'm wondering
there is sometimes
I love the entropic brain,
but sometimes I wonder in terms
of the connections, whether I don't how
we're having more or less entropy and
whether that matters the how. So for
instance, you can think of a free energy
landscape that's been flattened or you
can think of one where you're better
able and you have more energy for the
manifold activity is better of climbing
up or down the peaks that are there for
the more enduring belief landscape. So
it's like, in the moment, it could be
that my
previous way of thinking is unavailable
to me and I no longer believe those
things at any level. Or I can
support more novel inferences that I
wouldn't. Otherwise I can kind of move
into an area of mind space that would
otherwise be difficult, potentially
because of a greater energy into the
system, greater thoroughput noise.
Yeah. So as I think I understand the
question, right, it's basically asking
about trying to optimize for this free
energy variable
and in the context of deep canals,
right? Like this is the loss function
that's driving the optimization of the
learning landscape, the synaptic weight
landscape. Right. The entire
connectivity structure of the nervous
system is trying to get to this point of
low free energy. And I think there's
lots of for any given individual in
a given environment, assuming the
environment is relatively fixed, right?
There's like an optimal, there's a
global optimal. And it's very likely
that the individual is in some local
optima that is maybe close to it,
maybe far from it, but that's just
inherently what within the
context of the active inputs. That's
what we're assuming that the nervous
system is doing, is doing this
gradientism in the space and openness
then is going to correspond
to this plasticity MetaTrade or
be one of the components of it. And it
is in the deep canals model then going
to correspond to an ability to move
around this optimization landscape more
easily. Right? It's going to be a
flattening of the landscape, or more
precisely, I guess, a smoothing of the
landscape such that it's
less likely that the individual,
the nervous system will get stuck in
these local optima. So maybe it won't
mean that the individual will arrive at
the global optima. I think it's
difficult to say what that even might be
or how individuals might get to such a
place at all. But I think it is likely
that the individual will be more likely
to find a more
global optima and more easily move from
one optimal to another. And I think
that's kind of what this openness is
corresponding to.
Yeah. Okay.
In neural kneeling, I mentioned the
idea of psychedelic extrapolated
volition, kind of a play on a coherent
extrapolated volition from the AI safety
crowd. And it's this sort of sense that
if temporarily you have more control
over sort of low level shaping of
your cognition, your emotion, and maybe
sort of based on this attractor that we
call the self, or I
guess based on what is a good question,
then what are good signs? That you
should be trusted with that power or you
should trust yourself with that power
rather. And what are telltale signs that
you shouldn't trust yourself with that
power? And I don't have an answer, but I
think it's an interesting question.
Yes, I am normal and can be trusted with
the key to the doors of perception. Let
me in exactly. I have a short
question. Where is action in this
model?
So imagine
many places Arthur will get into that.
But for what I was thinking with Albus
is that actually the five HD two A
system. I talk
about two regimes, potentially.
One is more towards overt
inaction and modifying the world and
strengthened beliefs potentially of that
variety. And the other might be more of
adapting to the world.
Robin has a really excellent paper
called A Tale of Two Receptors where he
talks about five H T, one A receptors.
The ones that antidepressants tend to
act on because they tend to reduce this
excitatory signaling, talking about them
as a kind of passive coping. And so this
would correspond in there's some machine
learning models of this by Diane and
colleagues where they talk about
opponency between dopamine and
serotonin. And they're focusing on the
one A as a kind of like patients
promoting parameter, keeping you from
confidently charging into your policy.
So that would tend to inhibit, I guess,
patterns of either overt inaction or
potentially even some kinds of mental
stimulation too. You could maybe even
think of like even if you're not overtly
inactive enacting something externally,
there might be more or less brave type
styles of thoughts that you might be
willing to entertain,
going places you might not otherwise be
willing to go, and being able to handle
the swings in expected free energy.
That might happen as you try to pursue a
given path of policies. But the idea
would be that there might be something
more like a micro dosing mesodosing
regime which might be more of what
initially sculpted the five H two A
system which evolved with a gene
duplication event around the time of the
Cambrian Explosion with the advent of
jawed fishes. I'm personally
interpreting this as having the
significance of evolving in the context
of predator prey arms races. I suspect I
could be wrong, but that basically it's
locally trying to strengthen patterns of
policy pursuit to pursue particular
goals in a given context. And to come
back to what I was mentioning earlier
with that work by Robin of like a kind
of act of coping. But it seems with
rebus there's almost like not
that kind of story, and that it's
more you're adjusting to the world and
actually, if under a very alter state,
you are overtly enacting, that's
actually kind of a dangerous thing. I
don't know how much to make of this that
the five Http receptors are less
expressed on, like, motor cortex. I
don't think we know enough to make too
much of it. But it's like some dreams
you might not want to act out as they're
happening, but they still might
powerfully impact you. So I'm
currently actually wondering whether
this other rebus like regime might have
been specifically sculpted in the
context of bonding and
actually opening the self to include
others. And that might have been some of
the primary selective pressures. I don't
know how to think of that in terms of
inaction.
And one more detail that might kind of
like not sure what to make of it that
kind of goes through both of those
excuse the phone would be
anthropologically, I believe like
psychedelics are oftentimes used in ways
that would be both like creating a kind
of group solidarity and might be used in
the context of pursuing goals together
in the world. So for instance, like a
hunting party, they might all do
psychedelics together or something that
looks a lot like breath work before
going out, maybe going to war. So that's
a very different type that kind of
includes both a relaxation of the normal
boundaries of the self and a kind of
gearing you up for pursuing goals in the
you know, there's got to be another
story of like, so Arthur's expertise is
machine learning. And so it's like you
want these systems to act intelligently
and not act in other times. And so
basically now we're in the language of
policies, and when you deploy them and
how and so complicated.
Yeah. I would say that action manifests
itself at a few different places. It's
true, I didn't mention it here. Yeah, I
think it's very important, obviously. I
think what the kind of most implicit
place where it exists right, is that
these belief landscapes are being
instantiated ultimately for the sake of
adaptive behavior. Adaptive behavior,
adaptive action right, in some sort of
environmental context. And that's the
kind of like framework, the deep
learning framework that we're using or
like the artificial agent framework,
right. Is that the assumption is that
the system is supporting some sort of
agent that's embodied in some sort of
environment which is changing over time
such that it can either be adaptive or
not adaptive. I think then the question
of how action actually plays into the
evolution of these belief landscapes
during psychedelics or not acting
in the world is a very clear way to
modify one's setting, right? So acting
is a way of modifying the function
that's providing the sensory input into
the system which is going to change how
the activity patterns are evolving over
time, right, which are going to affect
the acute quality of the trip, affect
how beliefs are either being
strengthened or relaxed. And I think
it's already clear that there's a kind
of whole set of folk psychology
that's been built around what is or
isn't a good way to cultivate
a helpful setting and that of course all
is a function of action in the world. I
think then there's also this kind of
more subtler form of action which is how
one thinks, how one deploys attention
essentially during this experience. And
I think this deployment of attention has
a huge effect on whether there end up
being rebus or CBIS like effects.
Right? So whether one allows oneself to
go down certain thought rabbit holes,
whether one allows oneself to get kind
of stuck in certain kinds of thought
patterns.
I think this form of mental action has
a very big downstream effect and
I think a lot of I'd love to see much
more work on this. I think it's very
important, I think it's kind of
essential and I think this is kind of
one of the most interesting things about
these psychedelic experiences is that
in some sense, like the most extreme
rebus model and the most extreme thebis
model could be true for two different
individuals, right? Someone could say I
went to hell and I was there for 8 hours
straight, or say
I had a completely selfless experience,
I let go of all beliefs and experienced
nothing for 8 hours straight and it was
great. Right? And clearly those involve
two very different neural regimes and
I think the nature of that and
obviously, given that they involve the
same drug and they involve not such a
different setting, it's obvious that
they have something very important to do
with how attention is deployed during
this experience.
Yeah, I do think that this
frame of attention, I mean, attention is
so important for everything. And I do
think that there's something interesting
kind of digging into the Attention and
Albus framework that yeah,
I'm really curious to see how that'll
develop. I would also say that
in terms of active inference and action,
there is a cost to holding an intention
and then once you discharge your
intention, you can release that cost.
So I guess I would have to think
about how to apply that to the Canals
framework.
Fred Barrett, I don't know if he's
published it yet, but this is kind of
like a follow up to a Klaus truly
central model that Arthur alluded to is
emphasizing basically a lack of
executive control and placing that as
central to the psychedelic spirits.
Like not controlling your mental action
in directed ways as much and then trying
to counter more of the types of
cognition and phenomenology sort of
psychedelics based on just releasing of
the normal more agentic modes of policy
selection around attention as mental
action, although not using active
inference.
Yeah, very interesting. Adam,
your introduction there of course,
attention as covert action, which was
echoed by Arthur and Michael, both of
you said it really introduces a
case where we can use active inference
to find continuity between what's
happening inside the agent and outside
the agent. Because on one hand we could
kind of take a belief oriented frame and
we could say, well, what's happening
inside the agent are beliefs about
things, beliefs about hidden states,
beliefs about observations, beliefs
about policy. So that's kind of a belief
oriented view where everything is framed
basically cognitively. Or we could take
a very action oriented view and then we
could think about the interface in a
more inactive way and then also even the
realm of where many active entities
dare not tread in mental action with
attention as covert action. And so then
we have, like, a total active account
that is mathematically isomorphic with
the total belief based account. They're
both just maps. They're not the
territory. The territory is the person
in the room. So all of this is just
talking about the formalism and how we
choose to interpret the formalism in
terms of it being more inferential or it
being more active. And so there's a lot
of ways to go, I guess, in our
closing minutes, I would love to hear
what are the next moves or what are some
areas that you would hope that people
look into?
Michael and then the.
Know is, I think
my favorite mental move is to try to
drop down on my level of abstraction.
Okay, how is this implemented? What's
going on here? And then I do think that
details of implementation are really
generative to look into and, like, the
biomarkers and the proxies for figuring
out how to parameterize okay, exactly
how hot are we talking about with this
temperature parameter and so on in
different parts of the body.
I have kind of my niche that I'm working
on in the Vasomuscular system, which is
a rabbit hole. But, yeah,
I do think that the
deep canals framework specifically
and the canalization paradigm
in general, it's good enough that
we should be able to dig into mechanism.
So I'm looking forward to that.
Great. Adam or
Arthur.
You can go first. Doesn't matter. Okay.
Yeah, I'll go. Sure. Yeah. I mean,
first I want to echo this idea. I think
Mexicans is very important. This is one
of the people we've talked to about
talked with about deep canals. This idea
of, like, well, this is great. We have
these two axes. It'd be wonderful if
there were some biological correlates
you could look for. I think that's
incredibly important. My background is
also in machine learning, in deep
learning. So I'm currently doing some
work around simulating some of these
things. I think especially for these
albus dynamics,
being able to kind of study under what
circumstances you get these different
kinds of effects, even in kind of,
like, simple Tory models, is kind of
important to see how they unfold.
And then we brought it up at the end. I
think it's really important. It's very
interesting to me is the role of the
deployment of attention in this. And
there's lines of work where people are
trying various researchers are trying to
connect, for example, meditation to
psychedelic research. And kind of
certain people are trying to tell
unified stories about what's going on
in the brain when people meditate,
what's going on under psychedelics,
some of them using these active
inference models. But I think in all of
these cases, the deployment of attention
and how the deployment of tension
changes over time is kind of a key
aspect of this. And it's
not as present in the deep canals model
right now. But I think any
really robust future kind of like model
of these things is going to have to talk
about attention quite a bit.
Well, I guess next steps would be seeing
how the review process goes, but also I
guess helping Arthur to establish a
field of psychedelic machine learning.
Psychedelic inspired machine learning
where we try to make systems more
flexible and capable, better. They can
handle edge cases better, imagine better
in terms of real time policy selection,
learn in ways that not too much, not too
little, and then maybe so that's
useful, potentially earlier. Like you
have a driverless vehicle, do I change
lanes or don't I? You send it back to
the Tesla, dojo what do you want it to
learn, what do you not want it to learn?
But then down the line well
before we even get there, as you're
going into this you could see the
capacity for a rich bi directional flow
between machine learning and psychedelic
inspired machine learning. So it's like
you get a bunch of machine learners
together and a bunch of people who know
a lot about the cognitive science and
biology and maybe phenomenology of
psychedelics. And in addition to
designing better machine learning
systems, they could probably tell you
more about how psychedelics act. And so
you can have this kind of virtuous cycle
between the biology and the field,
but you keep going with that before we
get there. We'll keep going, but before
we get there. Very interested in the
implications for best practices. So for
instance,
oftentimes you might want semantically
neutral energy to kind of get them.
You're just turning up the heat, you're
just maybe at first breaking up, I call
them defenses, but the usual structure.
But then the question is at what point
do you try to direct the canalization
process? Do you wait till after or maybe
when the metal is hot, is that a really
good time to do it? And maybe there's no
one single question. This might depend
on the substance, the set, the setting,
the dose, the person. So getting clarity
on that could be fateful for many people
in terms of the outcomes they have. And
specifically what I'm gunning for is I'm
on a mission to make compassion
meditation treatment as usual for all
psychedelic psychotherapy and preferably
all therapy. And so the question is if
you're in a state of enhanced
imaginative capacity, maybe you're
having more ability to tune into your
interceptive system, whether you've just
increased the channels or maybe you're
better capable of because maybe your
inflammation went down a bit and you can
tune in better because it feels better
to do so. Some combination that might be
a really good opportunity to do certain
meditations that might update you in
particular ways like try to direct the
re Annealing process, maybe not just
like afterwards integration, but during
the session. And so if we could get
clarity on something like how to
canalize and recanalyze, like Annealing
schedules. It's going to be complicated,
but that's, I think, where we need to
head. And then finally for all this,
that would be enough. But recentering
the conversation on psychedelics, on
basically meaning and connection would
be enough. But I'm wondering down the
line, when we talk of alignment, we're
talking about our alignment with our
values and maybe the alignments of
machines with our values. And so does
this actually end up going to some of
the conversations that are happening now
about increasingly advanced AI and our
relationships to it? Could there be a
story of cannibalization and
recalyzation? You want some things to
hold fast and you want some things to be
more fluid. This might be it's always
been a timely conversation. We've always
been dealing with this with us, the
alignment problem of us, which we often
fail, but the alignment problem with
these technologies we're developing.
Okay, wow. Well,
so many great topics. Thank you all.
All I have in closing, turn on, tune in,
act in, first serve. Thank you.
See you all next time.